ross uh you brought the next story i did
you know if you're hiding holiday gifts
in your closet right now and you think
they're safe from snoopers think again
everybody
martha stewart living reports a new
survey by neighborly found the closet is
the first place people look
that's why i don't spend any time there
and for good reason because it's the
most popular hiding place by the numbers
followed by the spare room under the bed
and the the car trunk and the least
popular hiding places are the shed the
bathroom where are you hiding it in the
bathroom uh the toilet tank where would
you
i want to know were you a snooper though
were you that kid who tried to find the
presents and then open them up or shake
them i was buying the presents myself
frosty
oh it's that sad well i was a baller i
was seven years old and like this is
what i want for christmas i'll buy it
for myself
wow oh it got depressing it did right
then a little bit it didn't mean to
um here's
well i'll flip it on his head yet again
go get ready for this one my kids i
don't get them presents
i take them on a trip oh that's good
that's good
and
they will say
how come we don't have anything to open
and i'll say
you will open these memories and you
will carry them with you for the rest of
your life
and the thing you won't remember is that
toy under the tree
but i gotta tell you there is no wrong
and a lot of people can't take trips and
there's a million ways to do it and i'm
embarrassed that i even mentioned it now
no don't be embarrassed i think it's
beautiful you take them on a trip i will
say the toy under the tree is important
too i waited three years for a cabbage
patch kid and i finally got one his name
was his name was randy he was a libra
just like me and santa what took you so
long i loved randy but i was never that
kid that shook the presence i you think
i'm going to ruin christmas on my watch
no no no ho ho ho it's not going to
happen
um
but now i'm thinking a trip is such a
beautiful gift because it's like a lie
just like we'll go anywhere like just
get in the car let's go somewhere like i
don't wan i'm not good at the gifting i
wasn't brought up that way i didn't have
trees we didn't do that ceremony i was
brought up i spent every holiday like
alone i was a little confused by them so
i've tried to make the traditions
my own untraditional traditions and so i
just say i want us to have a memory at
christmas what i love about that though
is that so many people come from
different paths that don't look like the
cookie cutter thing we see on television
our own books so your tradition can be
whatever it is that you traditionally do
and you have just
you've just embraced that and made me
want to do that too
i love that
i love that well
speaking of presents
i'm really excited about this um our
little yellow book is a personal guide
that i make with the show we refresh it
every week stuff that
a curation of things that we're all
excited about
um and today it's the perfect holiday
activity for kids if you
don't want to take them on trips or you
don't want to get them presents i always
think crafting or something tactile
something that you can make is such a
great approach to things to give kids
and the kindness elves is what this is
these little elves live in your home for
the holiday season and every morning
they share one suggestion of a small act
of kindness you can do things like give
a family member a hug make a card for a
teacher donate a toy or a book to
charity these elves make kindness a
daily tradition everyone in the audience
is going to go home
with a kindness elf family
it's so cute
i love this so much
and it's someone who's just trying to
figure out how we're supposed to deal
with the holidays navigate them get it
right mess it up have an orthodox have
traditional
everything in between
i think
this to me is probably the most
important thing it's not something you
can buy
it's just being good to each other isn't
it strange that we have this window of
time where we say happy holidays
or we're nicer we're more charitable
we're more open-minded open-hearted our
behavior is a little gentle
i wish i could go for the whole year but
i'll take it in these times and i'm
happy to be with you guys this holiday
rocking those awesome christmas sweaters
ladies
and you are a 365 christmas gift rossi
in human form i love you so much all
right
[Music]